early trailers and gameplay footage of
resident evil village
have suggested the game brings the
slower more intense first-person
gameplay of re7
to a game world that's a little more
like resident evil 4.
the classic resident evil game that also
takes place in a village
an early preview of the new entry in the
franchise has suggested that this is
exactly right
ahri village looks like a combination of
re7 and the more action-oriented
re4 capcom gave us a hands-off look at a
relatively early portion of the game
which takes place in both the
aforementioned village and later in
dmitry's castle
the location previously shown in the
first ari village demo
titled maiden the village portion of the
game has
heavy resident evil 4 vibes with the
protagonist
ethan fighting off hordes of
werewolf-like creatures using furniture
to barricade doors
and explosive barrels to take out
multiple enemies at once
the combat also brings back elements
from re7 like raising your hands or your
weapon to block incoming attacks from
enemies
so you can take less damage
while playstation owners who jumped into
last week's demo got a sense of the
village portion of the game
our preview also included its next
section the castle
where ethan has to deal with the
vampiric lady dematrice and her
daughters
from the new hands-off footage capcom
provided the castle looks like a pretty
big change of pace from the action-heavy
village
very quickly ethan is captured by the
vampire daughters but manages to escape
their grasp when they leave him to seek
orders from their leader
mother miranda it seems like you'll
spend a lot of your time in the castle
trying to avoid demetris and her
daughters enough
games i love that man's head
now go of course mother if you run into
one of the vampires
the impression from the preview is that
you won't be able to harm them with your
weapons
like in the maiden demo the daughters
will disappear in a swarm of bugs and
reappear in other places to attack you
so ethan has to make a run for it
whenever he encounters them
that doesn't mean there's no combat in
the castle though as ethan explores
looking for those classic resident evil
items like crests to open locked doors
he'll sometimes encounter the
werewolf-like enemies from the village
area
in the higher portions of the castle
there are even some with bat-like wings
to deal with
to help you with combat you can visit
the duke resident evil village's
shopkeeper
anyone who is anyone has heard of the
likes of you
he serves pretty much the same function
as the merchant from re4
providing you with ammo healing items
and even weapon upgrades to purchase
you can also sell him valuables you find
in things like boxes and vases
so just like in re4 it pays to break
stuff and pick up
everything just know that you'll have to
keep your inventory tidy
in order to have room for all the things
you collect again
just like re4 though you'll sometimes
have to use your guns
the castle has a very similar vibe to
the baker house in resident evil 7
where you had to avoid enemies like jack
baker rather than try to fight them
ethan explores a lot of the areas that
were covered in the maiden demo
and he'll often find himself following
lady demetris as he sneaks around
eventually though lady demetris will
come after you herself
like her daughters she seems impervious
to your weapons the good news is that
since she has to duck down to go through
every doorway she's pretty slow and you
can outrun her
in the preview ethan loses lady demetris
by running through a few different doors
and circling back to the foyer area that
he's trying to cross
eventually in the preview ethan solves
enough puzzles to make his way to the
castle's upper reaches
and it's around there that our preview
with resident evil village ends
what's interesting between the village
and the castle is that each area has
something of a different focus
even though combat with enemies is a big
part of this game the village section
has a very resident evil 4
feel while the castle with its elusive
and seemingly invincible enemies
takes a page from other re titles like
re3 and re7
that makes us wonder if other classic
ideas from the resident evil franchise
might inform later sections of the game
as ethan searches for his missing
daughter
but we'll have to wait for resident evil
village to release on may
7th to find out we've got even more
resident evil village coverage on
gamespot
including the full preview of everything
we saw in our hands-off demo
you can also read about the return of
the mercenaries mode and the schedule
for village's upcoming demos
[Music]
you